covered cases in the uk are continuing
to surge with latest figures showing an
increase of nearly 800 000 in the last
week one in 16 people in scotland were
estimated to be infected and one in 19
in england the autumn vaccination
booster program will now be expanded our
health correspondent ashish joshi has
more
covert cases are going up again so what
is going on the latest data from the
office for national statistics shows
almost 3.5 million people in the uk are
estimated to have had covert in the week
ending the 6th of july
that's up
29 from the previous week so let's put
that in some context these are the
weekly covered numbers since last
awesome with the big peaks of the
original omicron variant in january and
april and now the more recent rise
driven by variants ba4
and ba5
how is that translating into the number
of people getting seriously ill the
number of people dying in hospital
within 28 days of a positive test has
been increasing since the first of june
with hundreds of people dying every week
these figures include patients who are
caught covered in the community or in
hospital and were already receiving
other treatments
this is highlighted by the number of
people needing a mechanical ventilator
because of covid that number remains
stable despite the number of patients
going up
these cases are however putting a lot of
pressure on hospitals with patients
taking up an increasing number of beds
and infecting staff the government's
answer an autumn covered booster and flu
jabs for those over the age of 50
frontline workers care home staff
and the clinically vulnerable
we're here we are in the height of a
heat wave
and we've got a a a peak in in
in covert cases now that wouldn't be the
case for other winter respiratory
viruses
kovid will morph eventually into a
seasonal winter respiratory virus but it
hasn't done yet
and and so i i don't think these
repeated booster campaigns will happen
forever but they may happen again over
the next few months depending on what
the virus does
the booster announcement takes into
account the rise of another variant of
concern ba 2.75 first detected in india
and growing quickly across europe the
key will not just be getting people who
have never been vaccinated to get jabbed
but in getting all eligible groups to
come forward in the same numbers they
have done previously